hello welcome to lobby gamespot's weekly
hang out every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com on
the Irish guy Daniel Dwyer joined by
everyone's favorite pure breed
non-regional host of the lobby Mike
McCarty wait pure read American yeah no
yeah yeah yeah the question was asked
are there any pure breeds left like my
hearty we're glad you're here I'm glad
to be here wait what about Justin what
is he Justin hey Walt I'm not our
Chancellor of news here at gamespot com
um what are you what's yours no let's
not get into this I I was like Kentucky
right yeah yeah I'm last yeah if I let
my accent come out I'm actually from
Kentucky just the middle America yeah I
love when Justin does his you teach me
phrases that you have in Kentucky which
we don't have in the rest of America
such as how much more you like how much
more you like so it's like I didn't
realize sometimes there are things that
I say that I don't realize right there
are regional isms and one thing that
will say is it somebody's finishing
something I'll say how much more you
like how much more you like like how
much more you like being done how much
more how much longer until you're
finished oh right that's what that means
how much ceilings I reckon where you
like with the store and how sorry that
was a mean thing to say I was trying to
figure how you used it continue by all
means I mean to damn I feel like an
idiot I ran into a regionalism today
where I kept saying I was talking about
like eight days from now and I kept
saying the wednesday after next I say
that or liking yeah you said I'm or no I
said all right a a little Wednesday yeah
so I wednesday week is what i said sorry
yeah that's a switch doesn't work here
right so it's always confusing yeah
there's a consistent way to say like
next wednesday and have somebody go the
next coming wednesday after the next
it's been hundreds of years we still not
forget a day yeah well some of the
greatest editorial minds in the world
here we select I do it the disaster
unbelievable uh we were to talk about
video games not grammar as it turns out
I'm not the wrong podcast well yeah we
looked at we had a meeting yesterday for
like why are we gonna talk about this
week because it always feels like pre
Madden like Madden is the day where okay
all the games coming out now we're into
it October september-october November
we've even got games
december this year were dead rising
foreign unzell sick a stick of truth
here totally and but I we load the stick
of truth already came out there right oh
sorry sorry captured butthole the
fractured butthole and it's just that
they're so similar but I'm looking
forward to playing as well well stick is
going but it's exactly it's all the same
but we have a bunch of stuff to talk
about today we're gonna talk about World
of Warcraft Legion which is that today
we you Justin in just few minutes gosh
mr. Rob handler yawns talk about fallout
4 nucca world which also came here today
which he's playing he's also playing the
battlefield one I guess the second beta
the one the desert map which and he's
been enjoying as well so we're getting
amounts talk about that and then also
finally the embargo has passed for
yourself and Rob's trip to 343 to play
halo 5 Forge yeah talk about that as
well cool in a little bit first of all
World of Warcraft's the MMO it just
won't won't go down is that and like I
feel like we've been talking about the
death of world of warcraft for for an
incredibly long time but it's such a
silly thing to talk about like I I think
we say that because it was the biggest
and it still continues to biggest yeah
but when you come down from like 11 or
12 million people playing every month to
now what maybe five six million yeah
like I i I'm sure they had a bump think
they've stopped talking about how many
subscribe they stop publicly talking
about how many subscribers they get but
I'm sure you still get a pretty big bump
around a big release like this totally
I've been in people nothing to shake a
stick out this is the sixth expansion
for this game and I mean it wasn't like
they were like there are expansions for
mmos that you know there were some mo
these to freedom every six months or
would you know they weren't very very
big but the expansions I mean burning
crusade this game gets a wacom in 2004
November thousand four I remember well
because we like God illegal American
versions back home so we could play at
three months before commandeur apiece II
came in 2007 Lich King 2008 Cataclysm in
2010 rewrote the whole map Pandaria 2012
a whole new area and warlords of draenor
back in 2014 and today Legion adding a
bunch more stuff and you played some
today and I'm interested to know what
that stuff is well there's there's a lot
and a lot of its going to be in-game
content this stuff that's immediate
is demon hunter which okay game you can
automatically roll the new hero class
kind of similar to death knight mmm
where it's not a new race it's a new set
of abilities you can jump into at a
specific level I think this one is 98
okay so it gets you really close to the
level that you need to be to experience
new content for Legion a new level cap
110 one of the more interesting things
that they've added in our the artifact
weapons so honest you're not you're not
going around you're not looting for new
gear in the info in the form of weapons
you're still getting new gear but you
you choose their you get an artifact
weapon you know based on the world of
warcraft mythos ashbringer Doomhammer
based on your class and then you get to
customize that based on the choices that
you make okay the based on the quest
that you complete within the the Legion
content so does that sort of take the
form of remember I remember when they
added its socketed weapons for instance
in the game is it that sort of thing
where you're like there are parts of the
weapon that you're sort of specializing
or putting you know I think it does have
some abilities like that but primarily
it's cosmetic okay what you choose you
get to choose how it looks because
otherwise like everybody is going to be
getting an ash printer and then
otherwise every ash pregnant would look
exactly the same rights are you to make
it your own you get to choose the
question and those quests let you make
it look a specific way and some of them
are really cool summer whatever yeah did
you get a chance to play some earlier
today I watched Julio play okay cool i
am not cut up my version so i'm still
somebody who buys the physical editions
right they make the best collectors
video games i don't buy a lot of
physical editions of games but you know
that just looks so good on yourself it's
ya book sitting there I worked launched
at a gamestop for a lich king and we did
a midnight launch it cork which is like
second biggest city in Ireland and we
had a line out the door for though for
those ones specifically as well like
they just make great sets and they look
right beside each other as well yeah
they line up really well they've been
consistent with it and if I didn't come
in though ah I did pre-order it yeah and
I got a note from amazon this morning
saying we're gonna we have to delay
shipment of this sometime between
September 28th and october 2050 so while
so I'm gonna screw this i'm just gonna
go buy it on best buy and i pulled up
and like oh no it's sold out online
every day
crap yeah so you can't just go and buy
your key because the interesting thing
now is that I think is that all of the
old expansion packs are no free yes
that's yes you can experience all of
that well let's see yes you can you
don't have to pay extra for that kind of
ice yeah she's not subscribed into it
yes you still have to pay for a
subscription in world of warcraft buzz
that stuff is also level for free up to
20 I think okay right which is like so
there's a little bit of that cracked a
little bit of that that first taste and
the power leveling stuff of course now I
was built in two hours well so fast like
a level 20 you get you get to level 20
in just a couple hours yeah that's one
of the reasons I think it's free is like
you can you might as well get your
characters up to 20 it's so much faster
than you know back in back in the day of
vanilla wow like that took that was a
feat for sure you played some wow as
well haven't you yeah I think I only
played about like 15-20 hours total an
orc hunter and yeah I think I got to
around level 20 does I sound right for
that amount of time all right now
probably like 30 maybe I just remember
everything and I was playing by myself I
don't when I play those kind of games I
kind of aside from like destiny i play
that for the coop purposes but wow I was
always just a very solitary thing for me
me too and I played the game for years
like I you know I played off past bc and
I guess yeah I was before that can i
sort of i dropped off and but every
single expansion pack that came out i
would go back so like I love to play in
Cataclysm when I first came out I did
what Pandaria as well I guess I didn't
so much of general but I was I was
looking forward to doing with this but
it does sound like most of the content
here is end game stuff right if I go to
the store wearing the wrong before it's
not gonna be super different I feel like
what yeah the world itself is not gonna
be that different but I think if you
skipped Draenor like I did run it that
it does feel like a different kind of
game I think dren ores when they
introduced a lot of the graphical
upgrades and all of that space you're
right so all the in-game cinematics
stuff is like totally alien to me like
I've not seen much of that at all I
think the game itself just looks better
it's still not comparable to some of
those Korean MMOs like those are some
gorgeous looking gay MMOs it didn't come
out 12 years ago well it holds up really
well that cartoony art style was such a
great choice in something in creating a
game that lasts that when you look at it
today and you you don't think that this
looks dated that it doesn't look like it
it doesn't look like a piece of crap and
it's like no it's made its stylized that
fits the
world in that game they've created like
wind waker on the Zelda series like this
I'm going to always look good that's why
I've been playing diablo 3 pretty
consistently since it like 2012 and
released was it and uh I on PC and ps4
and I don't think that will ever look
too dated i mean i played diablo 2 still
sometimes that looks dated but that's a
completely different art style wars
diablo 3 like the closest i've gotten to
like a stinking with blizzard for like a
super long time is diablo 3 honestly
just with the updates they are
introducing like the cube like all the
juice rifts that was pretty huge
adventure mode was huge when reaper of
souls came out and I mean there's one
thing you can say about visitors that
there we were seen with overwatch as
well but like consistently WoW is that
they've done a good job of trying to
retain people like the drop-off we're
seeing for instance in games like
destiny where people are coming back
every time there's an expansion back I
mean that exists the peaks and valleys
exist in WoW but they've managed to it
like if they've retaining five or four
or five million people that's quite
amazing they have that core you have
people who i'm sure played nothing but
wow and that is just their go to game
and it's always been their go-to game
and they even having those peaks and
valleys like you still have the here's
your core here's your base the people
that are gonna keep coming back to it
and then people like me that will go in
like oh there's an expansion here's some
new stuff I'll go in and experience it
we don't necessarily have time to commit
all of our yeah gaming time to just one
game but it's it's something enough to
draw you in and you have that core super
friendly super encouraging audience who
will help you along like so many times
when I get in the game like there are
just people who are higher level who
just want to help you out and yeah I'm
gonna do these things it's the complete
opposite of what you here with no but
it's like you have legends hit up that
RPG server as well just make sure you do
you know you speak elvish or whatever or
don't talk about Donald Trump in general
barons chat and the kick you have
dawdled from it's actually out in it
yeah Joanna dwarvish yeah I know I'm
gonna yeah just make some sort of troll
out of it ah so they go world warcraft
legion the latest expansion pack for
warcraft out today and yeah it seems
like it's i don't know from the cursory
looking at this and from hearing what
you're saying about who you're playing
it does look like it's mostly for people
who are been playing World of Warcraft
or maybe got to the end of end game
stuff and wanted to get more content
there I mean it's you can't you can't I
don't even know if you can make a game
at this point and say we're going to
entry
new people for sure that's good point
it's such a convoluted and complicated
thing I'm like if you're new and you
want to play wow like go play wow yeah
like you don't need the news those like
you've got 10 12 years of amazing many
levels and quests and contents I mean I
mean like and they've stream lighted
it's so easy to get into that now and
see like well is World of Warcraft for
me the expansion is not gonna convince
you you yet just try it out play those
first 20 levels and then and hopefully
you have a friend who can kind of help
guide you because it is still like I
don't think it's unfriendly I think it's
friendly or now than it ever has been
but it's definitely nice to have someone
who can encourage you in and let you
know you're on the right path for sure
there you go and let us know what you
think in the comments below did you play
wow in the past did you have you had
your interest piqued again by legion are
you gonna jump in or is enough for you
let us know in the comments below I'm
gonna get out of here yeah you're gonna
have your sorry Justin we've to get a
mr. Michael Hardy talk about why I was
the realest of games I'm here you're
here while we wait for Mike you kind of
talk sorry my way for Rob sorry that's
right all you white blond dude rob rob
is blonder is it'll say before he gets
here tell me you're playing Mother
Russia bleeds at the moment I am yeah
it's a beat him up its butt published by
devolver digital the developer escapes
me right now right um yeah I can talk
about the first four chapters okay
according to the embargo info will be
able to sort out juice it's really good
at a beat'em ups can become repetitive
and this is really good at actually
using the stage and the boss fights the
roxbury it again and we literally have
the camera on him walking in I thought I
but fair play I like it that
occasionally cause thanks we're talking
about mother OSHA bleeds sorry here ya
know it's a it's a really well-designed
beat-'em-up uh it varies the bosses and
the actual use the stage in cool ways
like the actual levels it's pretty
positive feeling so far like I can't
talk about the second half of the game
yet right I might reveal be up on the
fifth I believe if it goes up and
release day and need to double-check you
can over your shoulder looks like a very
gory looking Streets of Rage uber hyper
violent more so than Streets of Rage
infinitely there's also like really
adult themes you're in a
yessum clubs and stuff are you assonet
yeah I said I'm 41 sm like prison prison
Jo is a mess mm yeah Prison smm as
opposed to just the Civil kind school
band name Prison S&M yeah that's pretty
good it's my favorite Metallica album
prison SMS when they did set the new
supply metallica in a prison yeah Johnny
Cash that [ __ ] all right let's talk
about video games Rob handlery hey
you're here because you are our fallout
4 resident expert here sure gamespot com
and it turns out they have put at a new
piece of DLC new co world yeah you play
some this morning I did I live streamed
it cool gamespot com uh yeah it's fun I
actually compared to the last one far
harbor yes uh they kind of went all out
on this new setting the new co world
theme park Disneyland esque ok so say a
it's like the slurms mckenzie of the
fallout world it is a theme park based
around there coca-cola new Koko so what
is it like what does it how big is that
where is it in the map how big is it uh
is it in the existing map or do you like
no it's it's so it's in similar fashion
with all their DLC you start by checking
your radio or okay yeah you find you
know you basically get then a quest
which points to like in this case it was
the new co world like tram ride that
takes you off map oh cool uh similar if
our Harbor you get on a boat rice and
this time it's it's just chaotic this
whole this whole new map so it's like a
theme park that's like built out in the
middle of nowhere almost you take like a
train to it yeah like I guess most theme
parks are ya know it's just like what
just totally effed up yeah it's you know
as fallout fashion it's just completely
run down and this time around things I
guess are a little different again I you
know it's funny it actually took so long
just to get going in the new map yeah
they have like this huge I was looking
the chat some guy was saying who's
watching some other guy took like three
hours just to get through this crazy
trap-filled maze we're like you to every
corner I'm this latching was kind of fun
I was screaming cuz
there's one room for instance where uh
you know you you enter and there's a guy
on the speakerphone who's just kind of
making fun of you the whole time and
they're basically they also set it up
there are I guess three Raider factions
that are diverse and they all kind of
are fighting for power of the entire
theme park this I just love the concept
of this already yeah mr. state so each
Raider faction is just a group of just
[ __ ] yeah very much so and so are
you like trying to make your way through
this like fun house of death on the way
in or something it's like they've set up
all these traps for you to like yeah oh
my god and so it's it's kind of a cool
premise were they the radio even you
find out I mean this is kind of spoilery
but whatever it's because pottery you
just your Lord there and it turns out
that all the Raiders there uh just try
to kill people and learn them they're
just like budem they're all just Roby's
the [ __ ] you basically like kick off and
and they're doing like a gladiator style
you find yourself basically in this ring
against a guy with a power armor who's
like jacked up on like electricity and
you're just you know they immediately
take away your companion so my robot ADA
is not there I'm skiing my ass kicked
but this guy got it is so good uh ada is
like the ultimate I got the best hack if
I could ever have oh my god she's so
great uh she's got a ninja blade on one
arm and a gattling on the other so often
she just resolves fights like with
thanks baby she's got range on my legs
yeah it's great so yeah you could you
customize robson so in the area is like
new weapons are the new enemies
afternoon like what's going on ah new
enemies uh one of the first things that
I got attacked by was a flying ants
swarm okay so those are cool I can't
think of any other animals offhand new
weapons they could so they right off the
bat they introduced a squirt gun a
nucleolar squirt gun it has a cool
animation of you basically you know it
is fueled by nuka-cola horsham in yeah
it's pretty cool you pull it in and
against this bozo telling you is you
know the idea is that you take away his
electric shield in order to basically
then to damage on okay um I'm really
nuka-cola with this weapon yes it's
going away its water so it fries them
and then you can do damage so that's
pretty cool there's another weapon I
users just like machine guns I'm sure
there's other ones I saw one in the
trailer it
a what you call that toy with the rubber
ball Oh like a like a paddle paddle yeah
I don't know yeah the boring anyways the
trailer showed it being a I don't know
what's on it but it's you basically have
different types of ammo you can flick
these balls at people that are like
loaded with electricity or plasma are so
good I haven't gone that yet but um yeah
I imagine this pistol you can like mod
and to do different things i think i
would imagine maybe you know like
quantum Cola will have a different
effect right yeah maybe it'll freeze or
some like that i posted right now it's
just the vanilla water um but anyways
what I'm really getting a kick out of is
the map itself like when you compared to
far harbor where you get there it's like
what what are the gimmicks of that
island well it's foggy as [ __ ] yeah
that's about it and even that frame rate
was chugging here you have there are
different areas like you're forced to
kind of look at like a the map layout of
the park oh where do I want to go next
so right i just finished or most of it
doing what's called kitty was it called
Katie something right basically this is
the child a child yeah infants area
right park yeah and what's it's just so
funny like it's a very funny dlc ate the
whole thing is infested this area is
infested with ghouls right and there are
insane areas of just right radiation
where it's like when you take 20 rads a
second so like I'm playing a squirt gun
game and which actually spits out
tickets in the engine tickets and I
imagine you get like a you know you buy
a weapon or something like that later on
yeah that's cool you get your purple
paste out of your exactly and anyways
you know you're just playing these
little mini games as like I'm getting
taking rats or Google will come out
somewhere it's like really this like
it's like a good juxtaposition between
like totally I like this um yeah it
isn't fairly open right it's not you
could do this in any order you want yeah
you will fall out for in general yeah in
general yeah so like Indy kind of the
main market hub that's all situation
this is so much visually yeah so this is
cool this is so then that then i get
into the kid fun house and it's this
type of stuff you know just perspectives
changing or like there's one area was
called like a radiation may egg spinning
map were like it you earlier you hack a
computer to turn off the nausea mode or
some like that oh this was hilarious see
all these guys I just closed the door
it's like a rotating yeah map but I so
it's like imagine like the dumb things
you do in fairy in like in I guess
adventureland places but with like
zombies on them who were just stupid as
hell right and this one was really funny
so each as you'll see in the gameplay as
you go around the spinning room each
door has like a little funny gimmick
like I open one and I get in and it's
immediately just rad spray in my face
we're like another one it's um for doing
those perspectives illusions where it
looks like a really long hallway the
closer you get it's actually just
smaller smaller it raises right and it's
just it ends up being not a bar down
something Kevin McCallister just set up
all this [ __ ] for you to come crying to
me it's it's really fun and so that's
the the plus of this is I feel like for
even the price which I forget I think a
lot of these are what like 10 bucks but
so far this is just one little section
and I spent probably a good hour and a
half here cool 20 bucks and 0 20 bucks
so that's pretty fat yeah um there's a
lot going on like it's just from hearing
you described as it already sounds like
a million times more visually
interesting and mechanically interesting
than far r / 1 yeah absolutely it seems
like densely packed with crazy little
things i like the fallout self i guess
like it's one of the more interesting
parts of it is all the like references
to actual like life and culture unlike
theme parks are so dense with that sort
of stuff that i guess it's like this
perfect playground for them to just like
have fun with that stuff I guess yeah
and you could just tell the crafting of
every room feels like someone has like
gone either way to make it he'll for you
like the intro in the intro and it's
difficult right I think John Luke was
even saying I didn't know this because
I'm like level like 53 years in like
that um I guess you had to beat level 30
in order to enter oh right really oh I
must have this high-tech the theme for
ya what I know and I'm see exactly
that's funny guys going thank you and I
see uh see guys would like skulls next
their head I haven't seen those in a
while right of course laying there
really high level and sure enough I'm
using mini nukes plural to take them
down
um gosh so it's fun and I think I think
if you if you like fall out you had a
good time with it I think this is
definitely something to look into like
since it's a lot of fun I'm excited to
be on me I actually didn't finish our
Harbor I couldn't put myself to do it ah
just got bored this is something we're
like oh I can't wait to like go in this
room you know they do really funny
things where like I got there's a really
thin creaky a setup of boards and below
is just like this pit of radiation right
no I'm gonna be there for some reason
sure enough I open the door like think
I'm all scot-free wherever and then the
boars all break and Meyer lurks come out
and a guy near comes like oh my legs
here's like oh god I just died
immediately it's good money that's cool
oh here's a really good room so funny on
this dream I was just laughing my ass
off up you gonna room in gas mention
this right no gasps oh man and um you're
choking because there's gas and then all
these radroaches come up so now I'm
shooting you and then right away the
whole room in X in flames because my gun
fire is setting all the gas oh yeah so
immediately they're forcing you to use
melee weapons I got none I'm punching
these guys and then I get to one
legendary red roach ooh it's a big one
and I kill it and then I'm like okay
great and then it just explodes and
babies come out and like it's really 10
second memory yeah exactly just forget
in panic situations which is what no
clearly whether we're trying to add yeah
you do that it's just like clever that's
so cool all right now it's fallout 4
nucca world as today for twenty dollars
and on your platform of choice really
looking forward to seeing that if you
all more see more of that Rob's stream
should be live on case what lock on
right now and on YouTube pretty soon I
imagine huh okay let's shift gears shall
we a little bit halo five oh yeah i
mentioned to talk to you guys about this
because we couldn't get you one before
because of hella embargoes this games at
october 27th of this year and you guys
went up north to wait what what is what
our next oversight have another five
know so September 8th is
the 4 g's of this new update our Ansel's
legacy okay that's that's that's that's
let's rain it back then okay its rotor
27th of last sure I'm gonna blast you
yeah what am I Fargo let's write it back
its way back don't forget every forget
about the lower thirds genre just revert
yep there you go we're back at all right
okay live people you never saw it okay
it's been it's been a long long day got
really scared me to let me do we break a
huge a pagar go yeah it's gurgling my
meth okay we're good let's do it halo 5
horde mode hey whats up guys forge my
[ __ ] hmm I'm just thinking my gears of
war third time's jar I'm a pro always a
pro mic my hearty yep rajbhandari oh hey
you went up north to see head of five
forge mode mm-hmm the embargo is Dan's
now we can talk about us yeah tell me
why I should be interested in halo 5
forge mode like my hearty well its come
to pc now is the person i can be right
have one of those yes yeah it's a
Deborah eighth it's the night i play my
winamp songs yeah nine the way or what
when I'm okay really whips the llama's
ass remember that sorry continue pelo
fly it's a virus thing no yeah halo 5
forge mode is coming to pc now with
windows 10 it's a 9th update 9th dlc
anvils legacy I've been pretty
constantly just kind of revitalizing
halo 5 since last year October this one
is pretty interesting because forged
obviously previously has just been
consigned to controller input raja like
xbox one xbox 360 control scheme it's
your mess keyboarding this stuff yeah so
now you can you know click and drag
things as opposed to like tapping on it
and moving your analog you can you can
just manually like change the trajectory
of a man canon you can you can type in
like specific mathematical like numbers
like if you want the man cannons angle
to be like 45 points 350 degrees you
could do that whatever cool opposed to
liking the scale and slowly a guy's
house which is time and yeah for a mode
that is so heavily on like i need to do
this quickly because time is of the
essence does it give you more
and then as well yeah it's imagine like
a shooter playing playing shooter on a
controller as opposed to mouse and
keyboard except like 10 times more
easily now so is there anything else
that I'm just thinking about like PC
implants over consoles so is there like
is there more scaled can use more assets
in the levels and it like that um I
don't know whether they I don't think
there's any more like like memory
capacity or anything right and for the
reason being that they still want you i
mean you know you're limited on pc but
the idea is that you're still creating
maps for the xbox right can't you know
exceed any limit that the xbox can't
handle yeah right but you can also test
these the match you're creating on pc so
you essentially can just play custom
games on pc with mouse and keyboard
which we did we played probably like an
hour's worth or so a couple rounds I
mean that's so wild is that this is like
halo 5 on PC you can write a title you
can play with friends my matchmaking
campaign for free so yeah so how many
people can you get in there just to its
no custom game is 0 f e8 right sure okay
I think it's not big team battle so it's
88 right you guys don't don't like quote
me on that but that's like the typical
ok so this size 4488 right this is like
a tool that's been set up to basically
try and get more maps perhaps and like
halo 5 in the on in the xbox one version
but like you can just straight-up
download this make a bunch of apps and
just play them with your friends can you
can you can you import maps the other
that are on the xbox one version or a
play on the stuff that you've made
yourself right you can go back and forth
so it's it's very much a cross-platform
interface and like what was really
exciting to was um you know for someone
who you know I enjoy making maps but
like it very intimidating it takes a
while and on the Xbox one now they have
kind of revamp their whole UI for forge
allowing for featured maps yet seen
because you know at the other day it's
like okay I created a map in you know in
forge what now what do I do with it
where is it going to go how do I share
it sure enough you can you know like and
favorite you can it's got a bunch of a
revamp and keywords so i can find maps
easier it's a really nuanced search
filter you can take out like the person
they use
like if you played a map by like Turco
bango or ya can be like okay I like his
this map let me check out his other maps
you can say like I want this tile set I
want this kind of like people will like
can categorize it per game okay it's
really well like SWAT or whatever and
the most exciting thing is they have
they've pushed their prefabs which is
essentially like I can make a building I
can make anything in forge I can group
them all and then I can just send that
to the web in that you can just take
that Oakes all right really awesome and
I think this is just gonna expedite all
the cool map so you see because there
are some really great ones a lot of Star
Wars maps and stuff podracing someone
like takes a ghost yeah and is able to
put like the engines you know if like
Anakin's podracers yeah yeah so what's
really cool is like essentially I could
take that guy's all of his pod racers
just bring them in save me hours and
hours of time now all I can do is just
make maps right and make my own pod
racing map have they talked at all about
how like you for instance if you typed
in like a Mario into this like will that
stuff a beer hell yeah I think their
tether tags yeah you know you can just
yes search that say like I don't have to
reference like an old-school map if
you're playing like blood gulch yes if
you do that kind of tile set and you
don't want to take the time to design
the entire blue team's base of the tire
red team's you just search like capture
the flag base and it'll bring up the
preset like how about 35 40 items that
someone combined already and just place
those all on the map it's really cool I
mean and you're doing that like in your
own map right so you're not like exiting
your map and like highlight you just do
it in game just like old me search BAM
drop the bass drop it in and it's quick
and as it goes pretty cool so hopefully
I'll start them you know people do that
whole thing with a remake every other
you know 10 tournament in quake level
I'm yeah stick it in there it's always
part of like a wider effort I guess to
bring more I mean like yours a lot of
Xbox games gonna be on Windows 10 as
well right but they've set halo 6 will
be on Windows 10 they haven't confirmed
whether they're going to port halo 5 to
windows 10 although like we said there's
it seems like a matter of time like
because you know matchmaking forges on
there you know me perhaps maybe that's
it or maybe they're doing it the
opposite way whether they're going to
just lay the groundwork here so that
when halo 6 comes out that may be right
like all this stuff works there as well
or like a similar solar system appears
and the windows 10 have the halo app is
also like a hub for trailer as well as
that's where you're gonna play halo wars
2 through halo TV yeah hello there yeah
I'm like although like the miniseries
unforwarded on not yeah good stuff
interesting yeah super interesting
almost like a free version of halo 1 pc
and it felt good without some people
were like you know we were talking like
we play it's wat which was you know
headshots kinda lonely and yeah oh yeah
that's awesome it was fun course yeah pc
be a bit more fun it's great if you are
the kind of person who plays played like
old halos just to play custom games like
Lampard your friend yeah you can do that
for free right now at five that's
excellent go so when is this September
eighth okay yeah anvils legacy is the
name of the DLC pack and villes legacy
there are new racquet items as well
wreck items items acquisition if you
play hilly those packs that you call a
new weapons with say super mag also
features new rec packs check am at all
right yeah you got it all in you call
your halo stuff in there we got through
that section sorry I usually do a lot of
prep before these I did bombcast today I
was going in blind on the halo 5 forcing
your friday i'm sorry i called the gears
of war I'm sorry I called us or my horde
mode I forgive you i'm sorry i thought
the halo 5 wasn't there yet even though
it came out last year i thought you knew
something i didn't what yeah spoilers
alright this is the section of a most
excited about all day long because today
the second beta guess they're calling it
a beta open beta over beta is it the
first open beta yeah yes it is for
battlefield one is the first closed beta
i put in 22 hours into and it was one
map boy that game was fun you knew that
map totally right yeah and yet I didn't
because every time I played it it was a
different man like it was you know there
were changes to it ray it was a
different level of totally [ __ ] fund
right are we all in agreement that the
first beta was great mmhmm yeah we're
out pre alpha free for treasure so this
beta is open beta new map it's in the
desert trains and horses looks real
crazy I'm rob you were the only one of
the three of us who's played it you made
a bunch of the morning well I didn't
with me I played like 45 hours at e3
though okay
right so you have you've had experiences
as well but Rob first of all how does it
play how was the new map there was
always the worry that like Oh they've
got one good map in the red like the
rest of the stuff it won't be as
interesting what are your initial
thoughts of this um yeah I put it in a
couple matches already I think this this
Maps better really yeah what's the name
of it I actually Sinai desert yeah um so
you know what's so cool right off the
bat for me was seeing the sandstorms
right and you're getting a different
form of the dynamic weather that they're
like you know putting on these games and
yes sandstorm and then you get like a
cool overcast cloud covering the Sun so
it's like it just desaturate so
everything in coral down and next thing
you know it's hot again so I think
that's really fun to watch making
craters in the sand is really rewarding
all right great overall it is I feel
like they've added a lot um as far as
like graphics and visual fidelity yeah
it's really looking good and and it
looked quite sure honey like I did I
mean ran I was really surprised actually
ran really well on my OPC which is like
pretty good but not like amazing yeah so
yeah um you know I got in a plane and
flew around I'm you know big advocate of
the air combat and that again they looks
like you know before in the last pre all
the planes again this isn't a finished
game so I I realize they're working on
it but it's cool to see you know these
steps happened where the plane would hit
the ground and then just disappear kind
of ihop yeah I would that go you're
seeing a lot more wreckage now and when
I'm even more excited about is planes
previously you could shoot up ailerons
and then that would flex affect your
flight controls hmm it looks like
straight up wings are just gone real fly
yeah it was really cool so you're seeing
a lot more of this destructible nature
which is just like you know I think such
an essence of this game it's really
exciting to see so more of that I got to
ride a horse okay yes so tell me about
the horses can you shoot are the horses
I didn't have the heart killin but I
think you can I think you can not a
prime news for today because they kind
of look like they might just be looking
yeah like the motorbikes of this game
right where you're just using it to get
around and find people stuff totally can
they fire one on them yeah if so if you
spawn on the horse you your this
kind of like a [ __ ] specific class kind
of like if you're like a tank commander
or guy let you get this like lever
action shotgun right I used a d3 it's
it's tough it's it's one tiny little
reticle like the other guns but you're
on the move and trying to hit someone
with this one shot before you get like a
three second reload right the horse is
really like the horse as much because I
kept getting in tight spots at least
when I played III I don't know if
they've improved i'm guessing the got
pretty like long turning circles yeah
why would you couldn't turn but the good
thing is you can leap over like low
enough walls so like whereas a jeep
would hit this and then just you'd have
to go up into this mound around the
horse just leap over do you feel control
of the horses can you stop them turn
them yeah go anywhere okay it's not like
they're on a preset path like a
motorcycle that jumps things okay I
agree there there cough as far as
turning like many times I initially
found myself stuck in a corner some like
that and then at that point you're just
you know five people already looking at
you right so you're you're down maybe
with some level of mastery were like two
weeks into this will be like okay that's
how you might use those guys may be
right and like it seemed like the sprint
of the horse had like a long cooldown in
the limit amount of like stamina okay so
you know bursts of that I imagine you
get a blade a sword okay so I it was
pretty funny crazy ottoman like bending
looking thing that's better word um it's
pretty funny seeing these two guys go at
it like jousting tactics that was pretty
wild what about the train is so the
train is like the Zeppelin of this level
writing the best I miss their call you
it's it's the kind of like a rubber
banding not not so much but yeah it
circles the map now and it's it looked
like it's troy to you when i was
watching you but yeah well like watch no
problem it's just got big cannons on it
yeah you can spawn into it again I I
wasn't able to get into it because
there's the losing team that guy what
what's funny is uh yeah look like you
could essentially stop the train and
kind of go like whoever's controlling it
definitely someone is you can kind of
back up and go around like ok you see
the the whole outline that map it looks
like it goes around the whole thing
right and it looked like you don't have
to go one way right and take 30 minutes
to come back around or anything like
that what's more dangerous in the
northern side of the map where those so
the map is the map is actual
I completely agree with Rob it's I think
it's better than San Quentin skoura
first one this map is set up so there's
five control points at the top the
northern side then there's one random
the e1 is down in this open like desert
on the South go ases kind of looking
wrong it's cool so top is like almost
built up in the side of a mountain face
and then the track is only like probably
100 feet from some of those so that's
when the Train becomes if I understand
the train like starts the north west
point then goes down so it takes a
little bit for it to get back up north
but then once it does it's super
dangerous because it's and presumably
it's also bigger target right but if
like you're the the winning team you
kind of want to try to eradicate it
before it gets up past those 50 points
that's cool it seemed like it's
definitely close enough you know it's
basically like I'm just moving artillery
oh you can start pummeling the village
up in the North your clothes or the but
the the e is they'll wait oh yeah i
think it's close enough around there so
that's like a valuable things like okay
basically it gives reason to go around
the old map right yeah another thing
yeah you mentioned the map which i am a
huge fan of is again air combat is great
like I'm a huge advocate of a steep
terrain and in valleys and outmaneuver
people sure enough you know they have
like like San arches that you could fly
under and like really hog and can fly
between the canyons um when you're when
you're able to utilize the terrain and a
plane to like your advantage I get
something or six and you can kind of
like you know who's a better pilot but
let me hug this corner it's all I had to
do like mission or independence day
style yeah like just yeah wow yeah so
you're seeing that I think that's that's
pretty great as far as there's a there's
a few new weapons they kind of pull back
on some things too okay it's like they
took out some weapons but they've added
like assault class is basically you know
compared to the previous game if like
they just meshed engineer and assault oh
you're very much an anti-tank
anti-vehicle guy now so they added
dynamite so you can throw down dynamite
roll it up perfect for the train you're
making crazy you could like ostensibly
make what you did you were making
craters earlier at e that southern
outpost if you had like no cover if the
building was ready to make a crater and
duck into it right right and you totally
need to because it it's so far away
there are just these stretches of sand
dune
which are fun to hit with the Jeep I was
really fun but yeah you you're gonna
need cover because I was in a plane and
toots five dudes are just running across
the sand dune trying to get to e do I
was just knocking oh yeah just rotation
yeah yeah not attack so uh I think of
much more diverse map and I think this
looks great again like for something as
simple as overcast right in a desert
yeah and which is like a pretty
monochromatic everything Wesley is weird
to get it super geeky it's this weird
like confluence of the Mediterranean
weather and the desert weather right oh
so this is actually yeah you don't care
about the history and not go for it
alright so as the sinai campaign british
were essentially just trying to control
suez canal against ottoman empire it
actually got kind of like overlooked but
it was like it took a while i was like
1915 until right 16 you said it was like
almost like the world war two marker
course our oil in version of market
guard well Gallipoli was in the
australians land and we're trying to
like pierce the Ottoman Empire this was
more defensive thing on the British all
right but I don't like I don't want to
talk to the full game before it comes
out October because again this is a beta
but this map what it like excites me
about it is that like obviously
Battlefield games live or die by their
level design their maps as most shooters
do but battlefield even more so
definitely this one you actually play
the entire game differently i was
telling rob like San Quentin scar felt
like just wide open space and it was
good for like different viewpoints and
sniping and like vehicles would be
better up certain approaches but that
felt like this big battlefield where
there were these separate skirmishes
raging all over a certain control points
south and the north were like two
different things right and this one
still kind of like that but the fact
that the train you can't control where
it's going the train is actually
circling the map and also the fact that
there's this one lone outpost it
actually feels like the entire thing is
one big cohesive battle because there's
canyons so when I was planning a III
like my team was trying to push out of
these canyons we took the central
village the north and then we were
pushing them back into their canyons but
then the sandstorm whipped in so they
like I don't know if they meant to or
not but they took the chance because we
were a lot of us were sniping they took
a chance for the concealment to come and
push us back whereas like the next time
I played me and six other guys and I
just went down held EV for the entirety
of the map and like when the train came
really oh my god we just like hunkered
down like five of us died there's like a
cup of us left but it feels that's why I
like Bell feel one
exciting me right now again I can't
speak to the quality full game I haven't
played it like no one has but it
actually feels like they're these you
have a sense of the overarching battle
that you don't in like a lot of other
games and even like recent Battlefield
games yeah i mean i am fascinated to see
what people think of this open beta
because we have a lot of like I think
like I think it's fair to say like a lot
of us are bad for fans but we're also
like skeptics like coming out of three
and four for Mosley as I'd like oh yeah
yeah like but like there's been nothing
but we've enjoyed so much of playing the
original beta and it sounds like this
one's fascinating as well from what you
guys are saying so I can't wait because
like you know the press can talk about
it for as long as we want but it's not
until people actually get hold of it
that we can kind of like you see that
like tide change and I really think like
this is the best but it seems already
like it might be the best battlefield
let's come in a long time and yeah we
haven't seen any of the campaign yet
either right yeah i mean like that's a
majority of people that's not the main
draw I between like having a background
in like looking at World War one history
but also just the fact that like if they
can talking about like other people like
how big a part video games playing
romanticizing war no it was like because
you movies did that for a while the 50s
and 60s and like the 70s comes long you
have the deer hunter and then the
eighties comes along a platoon those
movies realize is kind of messed up to
do that whereas games are still an
entrenched in this like romantis asian
you have people yeah spending sixty
dollars and pre-orders to play a game
set during the some of the worst moments
in human is right i like ya not to get
like to pc about it but like if they can
actually use that and kind of examine
like how messed up world war one was
that's interesting me but if they just
kind of exploit it i guess i'm just
gonna stick the multiplayer again but
i'm curious about the campaign because
even just for the sake of having new
types of games to play like we've played
like medal of honor was very much dodge
and they were amazing call of duty was
very much off at the first couple of
years and those are amazing but yeah
you're right like it would be great like
spec ops the line is one of the most
interesting that's the one like like
stories about war I've ever seen I like
it's basically like a video game version
of a popular movie but like but like
it's a yeah like I'd love to see more of
that stuff not just for the sake of like
war is bad but also just because games
haven't really explored that at all yeah
in right and you're right like if there
was ever a war to do it like world war
one whenever you like do your little
you searched every couple of years and
learn about it it's like uh yeah worst
and that's why they said it was the
great Wars will never do this again oh
[ __ ] we're doing it again it's really
bad it's like the obviously the Geneva
Convention like so many rules about the
rules about war now because of where
were one yeah not anybody amazed don't
die not even in the bottles like I just
bend across the world as a man influenza
first anak first-hand accounts of like
uh not to get I don't want get too
graphic but like first-hand accounts was
like trench like just living in trenches
after a while the trench itself is just
like coated in yeah it's coated and just
like all sorts of human feces and in
like humans all right all right gone a
sludge that people describe though my
gosh cussing it's tough to yeah so I
know how the campaign yeah uh needs more
lunch oh my god you really see the slaw
your paws proper job yeah late in 4k you
really got the sludge look at this slide
yeah what is that a are you like driven
I just have this idea of like this
matrix like like purple guru yeah it's
like well how are we need to be secretly
goes made of people that stuff that they
were in they like to our winner nitrous
I think that stuff there in in the
things pods was also made of like humans
are batteries in that room yeah dad bet
that's what you do with dead batteries
yeah video games all right let's get out
of here thank you so much for watching
la vie actually before we go uh what are
you working on reviewing Mother Russia
bleeds school right at the end but I
yeah first four chapters pre-cool
variation on the beat-'em-up formula I
just be inside the other day sweet oh
yeah finally took me I think like three
hours yeah around that how'd you enjoy
that I like to eat a lot more than I
thought the ending with island without
saying anything about it I like the
ending a lot I kind of got spoiled a
little bit by the ending me too yeah
knew how Alex new house who is departed
for a few months is a deposit playing it
next to me at Alexis desk when she was
out and like a spoiled guys play liking
it's such a game we're like yeah you
just the you want that impact to have
like just no good like no knowledge
going in I like I was like I was kind of
hinted at something and I was like
waiting for a and then that was the
bummer that it's yeah yeah it's almost
like one of those movies you go tell
someone like I tell you anything about
this yeah go see go see ya right i got
that with a let the right one in the
swedish version yeah I don't knew
nothing about and I was like yep that's
a great way to see that movie cuz it's
like this is not the movie I thought it
was the cabin in the woods as well yes
also this year if you don't till dawn
yes or midnight special my dad schooled
is so bad he was really yeah he's like
it's a great movie and holy God that
first like what 20 minutes yeah we're
pretty intense was like a this is like a
really good like Tarantino movie yeah
like what oh my god my dad was laughing
so hard he just sold it we're like this
movie sucks is not awesome that's good
stuff what are you working on the road
ah man I really want to play battlefield
as much as I can but I think I'm too um
definitely make some for some sort of a
fallout feature cool nucca world I think
it's becoming a really cool do you'll
see i really want to keep playing it i
am very sad about after our chat today
i'm also trying to like find time for
like deus ex cuz i was waiting right
yeah that's i touch that i never got to
play either of the time full attack
betas XYZ and again this weekend i'm not
gonna get a chance but i'm very lucky to
go to go to pax so myself John Luke an
x-ray and Scott Butterworth and Marco
we're gonna head up there to Seattle and
I think some of the guys are doing the
panel's i'm doing the packs rumble with
alexa and so if you're up there you see
us give us a wave say hi we're gonna be
up there shooting previews seeing what
games right there it's a couple of
announcements coming out of it and then
a lot of like indie self as well we'll
check out so cool she'll be good yeah
look forward to it all right gentlemen I
see you guys next week see y'all you
next week thanks so much for watching or
listening to the lobby every Tuesday a
tune p.m. pacific right here on gamespot
or in your ear buds whenever you goddamn
like thanks so much for hanging out I
will see you next time oh oh sorry two
things keeping thank you to air tay
jean-luc psyche richard lee marrakech
all the people who work so hard to put
the show together and there is a
battlefield one stream starting right
away so slick around us
right here oh you're gonna do it yeah
get out of here that good all right
we're done adios see you next time stick
around battlefield ones happening it's
shoot some horses back